today we're going to look at positions
like these and and make fun of the
people who made bad boobs right okay so
this game was played about three weeks
ago in the ninth championship why was it
played in the ninth championship this is
chess for Knights now that joke was too
complicated for most of you okay now
this position is equal you'll notice
everybody has the same stuff everybody
has a queen everybody has two rocks
everybody has a king everybody has six
pawns and both sides have a minor piece
however White has a lot of pieces near
the black King right so what black needs
to do is defend his King then he won't
get checkmated now okay so the best move
according to the computer is rook to d6
and the rook is defending the
third-ranked again instead black made
the losing move okay then you have to
find out why it's losing because it's
chess for Knights why they're black
moved pawns in front of his King boo he
needs pawns in front of his King so his
King is safe instead he played the move
f6 breaking one of my very important
rules Bensimon did never play f6 okay
and now instead of a drawn game he got
checkmated then what did he do after he
got checkmated he cried okay so how did
white open up blacks King and get rid of
those pawns Arjen he played Knight takes
h6 BAM notice how it's check and black
said thank you for the free night now
black doesn't have a lot of pawns in
front of his King does these Kings sort
of open okay now how did white continue
the checkmating attack
argent again queen g6 and now black made
the best move King h8 okay now there's
more than one way to win for white okay
so let's see if somebody can find one of
them yeah Sam
Queen six age six black made the best
move then after Queen g6 it was
checkmate okay also white could have
played rook h5 immediately and then rook
takes age 6 is going to be checkmate
either way it's made all black had to do
was defend with rook to d6 defending
everything instead
checkmate immediately with Knight h6 and
black has no pieces in front of his King
there's a lot of pieces away from his
King
that's pretty safe right no terrible
okay
so black lost even though his name was
Ben he still lost amazing okay we won't
save that because he lost all right now
I have a student who's currently playing
in a tournament fat I can pull it up
right now
that's live every move is red terrible
there's a tournament in Texas and
Matthew Larson one of the finest players
to come out of st. Louis my student for
five years he's playing right now this
game is live and now it says he's better
he's been better worse than equal but
not at the same time okay and when the
move is in red that means it's a bad
move you see how many red moves there
are terrible
okay now Matt Larson occasionally
checkmates his opponents and
occasionally they checkmate him
that's chess for you and this was a game
he played against the Grand Master last
month and white played Queen to e3
and now Matt Larson made the losing move
boo actually computer says Black has the
advantage here
okay that's why chess is so tough if
you're playing football and you're ahead
49 to zero for example and he's Super
Bowl in the 80s between San Francisco
and Denver okay and then you blunder
then you're up 49 to 7 and you still win
in chess if you're winning and you
blunder then you lose one bad move loses
the whole game in this position if two
computers were playing black might win
but two humans were playing and the
human Matt Larson played rook to be
seven gay which is a bad move and now
let's see who the smartest is justice
tis White has a winning move in fact
after White's move black gave up so he
went from a better position to giving up
the next move terrible then you learn
from your losses isn't that good now all
right so what's the winning move for
white it's a brilliant sacrifice
eventually leading to checkmate
checkmate is worth more than a piece you
got pointed right at you what's problem
rook takes Bishop okay and after rook
takes Bishop black gave up because he's
down a bishop okay now the best move for
black is to not take the rook then he'd
be down a bishop so let's pretend he did
take the rook because usually taking a
rook is better than not taking a rook so
you take the rook now White has a to
move check me which we saw a lot in our
last class so if you're in the last
class that should be pretty easy
how does white checkmate black in two
moves you must be at least four years
old to answer yes he's like I'm four you
raised him right away then no what
should white play
correct Queenie six I knew if you were
like more or less than four you wouldn't
get it but four is the right age
Queenie six check Black has one legal
move and therefore plays it and now
White has checkmate in one move
you must be exactly 40 answer yeah
tough class what do you think Frank
what's the checkmate was that you Ben
Simon ah there we go
now Frank sees it before he was like
he'd see it
how does White checkmate black and one
move it looks impossible yes you're four
I think yeah really yeah right without
did you used to be for like a few years
ago he's like maybe Queen goes up next
to the king
Queenie eight checkmate now my one
o'clock class yeah that was your move
right yeah but yeah but see in the one
o'clock class they castled here King
here rook FA it and people are slow
today if you put Homer laughing they're
like what's the one o'clock class
okay so checkmate so instead of getting
checkmated Matt Larson gave up boo let's
see if he lost already
hmm Knight g4 check he did was Matt
Larson blundered his Queen okay so in
this position Matt Larson played Queen
e5 and his opponent played Knight check
for King the king and queen that's
happening live although not for you at
home okay and then Matt Larson is going
to resign so he made one bad move and
now he's going to lose we're ok though
chess is tough okay here's another game
and in the 1 o'clock class we did check
meat into this is the 2 o'clock class so
we do checkmate in three what are we
doing the 9 o'clock class
so close anyone Arjun now what we do in
the nine o'clock class Arjun
now the maths too hard for them Sam you
know your parents you're here too come
on you two get close enough okay so
black played notice that White's
threatening Queen takes rook which is
also mate so black played Queen e5 now
White has meeting three with a
deflection fee theme that wins the game
because blacks queen is overworked if
blacks Queen was off the board white
could play Queen g7 mate Bishop g7 mate
and Queen takes rook maid but the Queen
on e5 is stopping all the checkmates
okay but the Queen can't go to both
squares at the same time so white has a
trick that check lates black let's call
on a random student Arjun Bishop to g7
attacking the king and the Queen okay
black has one legal move King 2i8
oh wait is it i seven now so he has to
take the bishop nothing's funnier than
that okay
Queen says Bishop now what is why do
Arjun Queen takes the Queen trade Queens
Queen takes rook now the Queen Lee was
on e5 was doing a good job but Arjun
made the Queen move off of a five now
the rooks not defended now you can play
Queen f8 or Queen g8 they're both good
moves now but you have to so actually
after Bishop g7 Matt Larsen resigned
we're going to rename this class to the
Matt Larsen resigned class okay and then
he could he could also go here and then
check me notice the bishops that's
defending the Queen okay so yeah
question
oh yeah so white wins
okay so Bishop g7 good job all right now
in this position white has two captures
but he played the wrong one so Matt
Larsen want a game instead of losing we
couldn't believe it
okay the the media were notified white
could play Knight takes pawn or Bishop
takes pawn and he chose the wrong one
okay he played Bishop takes pawn notice
the bishop is defended twice and it's
attacked twice so that's fair right okay
now there's an idea in chest you've
never heard of especially Arjun called
removing the defender so you want to
take something but it's defended so you
get the defender move out of the way and
then you take the piece that you can rub
your hands together because it's cold
outside right yeah he agrees so what
move can black make to remove one of
these defenders that he could take this
for free which actually is sort of what
he did of the white decided to lose a
queen instead interesting decision all
the way in the back f4 trying to remove
the defender the knight which answers my
question correctly unfortunately that
doesn't win the game unless it does win
the game hmm might win the game then you
could - there that's probably a good
answer
your answer is better than mine as
Groucho Marx would say yeah 1985 was
played but I like your move - I think
your moves not quite as good because I
can play Knight f7 check and then this
is sorta this is sort of fair it's a
little fair rook it upon for two pieces
okay and the move that you suggested
second attacks a bigger piece Knight a5
that's a big piece now
if white tries to do the same thing then
he loses his queen
okay and if white moves his queen away
then this Bishop is free there's two
pieces on it and there's one piece
defending it so why did something
drastic he gave his queen away took the
rook and took the night so you got a
rook in a night for a queen what's
better a rook in a knight or a queen
Queens a little better and black
actually won in like six moves okay now
let's go back I'll show you something
really complicated which nobody saw
neither players saw you know who did see
it the computer saw it yeah the computer
said you should take with a knight not
with the bishop and then after Knight a5
you should sacrifice your knight and
then you should play Queen here
threatening checkmate checkmate is good
because you win how does black stop
checkmate probably stopping checkmates a
good idea right Sam okay you how does
black stop checkmate careful checkmate
how does black stop it who wants to help
you want to help you have any cash on
you
pawn age six now we have a discovered
attack fork which is really good in the
restaurant the fork part anyway Martin
Knight f7 forks the King and Queen and
the Queen's attacking the Queen
everybody's happy except black black
takes the knight and we win the Queen
with check then we win the knight next
move and okay so that's how white should
have done but neither player saw any of
that okay instead white played here and
and then he gave up poor him okay so
that was a good game now the difference
is after Queen here
Knight takes Queen here we can play
Knight f6 stopping me and you can't play
Bishop takes rook because you have no
bishop that's why he should have taken
with the Bishop because his Bishop got
captured okay so sometimes you win
sometimes you lose
now this game was played before you were
born okay
well not you but everybody else okay and
in this position I'm attacking my
opponent's Bishop so did i take his
bishop I did not take his Bishop but I
had a good excuse you know my excuse was
it's a really good excuse Sam that's a
reasonable excuse but not in this game
but usually that would be right my
excuse was it wasn't my turn to move
that was my excuse it was my turn I
would play pawn takes Bishop what did my
opponent do about that did he let me
take his bishop and he sort of did but
later yes what did blank do about pawn
takes Bishop Knight we're here and then
I couldn't take his bishop you got me on
that one then I would take his knight
then I would take his Bishop alright how
do you save your Bishop then in the back
Bishop h6 well you're right I wouldn't
take his bishop then I take the other
one
this should be six I would take his
Bishop a free bit I take the other one
next yes
correct he took my pawn that's what he
did now some of you have noticed if I
take his bishop he'll take my bishop but
this was a 1987 and Barney the Dinosaur
hadn't existed yet which is strange
because dinosaurs existed a long time
ago anyway so there's no I take you you
take me that none of that I want to take
him for free okay and I did something
that you usually see in other sports
like soccer and football called
interference okay
I don't want his queen defending his
bishop so I interfered with it I blocked
his Queen from his bishop let's call on
a random student argent
I played e6 that's nothing to sneeze it
that's a good wound
okay now I'm attacking his queen and his
queen is no longer at protecting his
bishop so a Grand Master would probably
resign probably okay instead he took my
pawn and now what did I do
take his bishop right now I'm ahead of
Bishop and Bishop takes pawn check is
coming or Knight takes pawn or pawn
takes pawn okay and now he actually gave
up he's down a bishop and he's going to
get in a lot of trouble okay a lot of
trouble for example even if he saves his
queen check now he's even he's in the
worst trouble because my rook is going
here okay
so that was terrible so E 6 is the key
move I want to take his bishop but I
want to take it for free so now when I
play e6 his Queen and Bishop don't
protect each other anymore
so E 6 good job I wonder who found that
oh yeah I did all right now this is a
famous game that you all know and what I
mean by that is none of you know it
that's what I meant but a couple people
at home know it we have about 800
million viewers two of them know it the
other hundreds of millions are like what
ok this is a game kappa blanka played
kappa blanka was the world she
peon from 1921 to 1927 unless I'm wrong
which is possible yeah he beat Lasker
and he lost to Alekhine this is a game
he played in 1914 were you at this game
were you watching it live the showing on
the Internet why weren't you watching it
ah that's why you were playing chess
calm in 1914 it you weren't watching
this game we could still cook on the
internet then what's your problem is his
excuse for everything he wasn't born yet
okay so in this position the guy with
white wanted to take this pawn and kappa
blanka wanted to Queen his pawn okay the
other guy we haven't heard of so
probably kappa blanka 1 ok
so white played a fork 9 to be 5
attacking the rook and attacking the
pawn and White has a lot of guys
attacking this pawn now who wants to
play Queen takes Knight ok anybody yeah
there we go
Queen takes Knight is risky because then
white will take the Queen that's risky
so instead black saved his rook and
played rook c5 attacking the knight and
white did exactly what he wanted to do
Knight takes pawn and White's up upon
her a good but kappa blanka he wasn't
playing around although he was playing
around ok he traded the knights and then
he traded the rooks now black made a
very famous move all grandmasters who
studied chess
know about this position because it's a
very famous trick fat
I think RJ was looking at in the last
month maybe let's call an unknown
student you okay queen b1 is that
checkmate
what should white do scratching his head
in confusion who is incorrect you what
yeah yeah so here here how about here
all right yeah yeah now if black tries
to win then white plays check me so that
didn't work out too well okay so I was
tricking you earlier you know why tricks
are for kids an Arjun will now give the
right answer which you already gave
arjen's like what Arjun you've looked at
this position I've seen you looking at
it but it was like four weeks ago so
you're confused I'll just say it was a
whole year ago what was the move you
suggested that we scoffed at not what
the move before that what did you say
you suggested another move who remembers
what he said What did he say
queen bee to the right answer your
favorite mistake that's the right move
okay
notice the Queen's attacking everything
right and if Queen takes Queen then
checkmate and you can't play checkmate
in this position because the Queen's
defending it so you play Queen to b2 now
Queen takes Queen allows me you can't
let black take all these pieces what if
white defends his rook yay now his rooks
protected now why it's all fine right
Arjen you're taking the RIC anyway that
wasn't very nice and then checkmate
another move is rook to c2 now Queen b1
works because when the Queen goes to f1
we take the rug yeah so Kappa blanket
played Queen B - and his opponent gave
up this upon didn't see Queen B - notice
neither player got left okay
left is a German word for air okay also
it's also German for we're on strike and
nothing terrible even at home they're
confused okay and if why did plate h3 or
black had played h6 earlier in the game
there's no back rank checkmate comment
if you play King to f1 then I would
probably play Queen takes rook and B up
a rook might be a better way of playing
I don't see it so I would take a rook
right then you'd be down a rock and
since it was kappa blanka and he was the
world champion being down a rook is bad
if you're taking notes being down a rook
against the world champion is bad you
don't do that being up a rook is good
that's better yeah okay so Queen B 2
wins the whole rook so white gave up
white was like I'm a pawn up I'm gonna
win then after there he went oh I'm not
going to win okay
and Kappa blanka's saw Queen B 2 all the
way back here he knew that white
couldn't take that pawn but white didn't
see far enough that's why one guy was
the world champion and the other guy we
never heard of yeah this is a tough
position I can't figure out what to do
why does it say black to play what's
going on here oh okay that's right
okay so in this game okay
this is a game I had about three years
ago and I played rook here however I
could have played pawn to d6 and then I
would make a queen and I would win
everybody would clap right after pawn to
d6 black is actually winning so it's
good I didn't do that black can fork two
of whites loose pieces look at all of
White's pieces are they protected or
unprotected unprotected and now black
has a winning sequence of moves which
attacks too
of them again I'll give you a hint black
can attack these two pieces although he
has to make another move first
I wonder how black could attack a look
at a bishop that are so far away there
should be like a flash bag this isn't
family guy yes II five attacks the
bishop but then white would save his
bishop we know a way to attack both of
these pieces we can't do it right now
but we can prepare to do it wonder how
you take both of these pieces that's too
hard
nobody can do it even Arjun stop crying
Arjun no crying in baseball did you
bring me Kit Kats
tomorrow but throughout my day off next
Sunday is my last day here so that's
good job it's like a present yeah also
I'll call on you more if you bring cash
you know blue waters all kinds of stuff
yeah and send your money caravan
Feingold two four six five seven
Maryland Avenue you in the back Queen a3
is 2/3 correct the best kind of correct
after Queen a3 White has five thousand
legal moves I can't analyze them all
okay but Queen a3 is almost right anyway
you have to make a move where white
doesn't have too many legal moves um you
know yeah Queen where Queen before what
nice Queen before attacking the bishop
then white will save his bishop so
that's a queen a3 Queen before you're in
the right ballpark yes
Bishop takes pawn is risky because then
white will take the bishop it's risky
because White has two guys defending
that pawn this rook and this bishop by
the way I didn't see this move either so
I was going to lose if I played it you
you're pretty old queen d4 already
suggested is a good move but there's no
way to attack that rook later we want to
attack the rook and the bishop that's
almost impossible you rook b1 Shaq then
I would play King h2 and my king is safe
see I have looked unlike my opponent see
him with the wrong insert calling
somebody else you Queen to h3 then pawn
takes Queen with advantage that pawns
defended I would never undefended an
accident
Arjun Queen a1 check notice how it's
check did you notice that okay and white
easily gets out of check no problem now
finally black hasn't moved that Forks
these two pieces Arjun Queen a for
attacking the rook and attacking the
bishop and then I would have lost this
game that would have been financially
not good again instead I didn't play the
move d6 I played rook da and he still
forked my bishop and rook what a mean
guy right but how do I save them both
Martin
that's what I did okay and now his
bishops pinned and my pawns pretty good
and eventually I won the game now here's
the last one it's too hard for this
class this is more of a nine o'clock
class you know I'm eight and ten which
one have you got by the way okay so in
this position black is threatening
checkmate that would be good for black
right okay
however white has checkmate in two moves
so if white checkmates black then black
won't checkmate Wyatt mate in two moves
okay we'll start with the wrong insert
Queen f6 I'll take that okay next I like
the way he's always right and then
doesn't know he's right that's good it's
a solid what real queer rook here then
checkmate that is also meeting two but
for the wrong guy Martin pawn takes
Bishop equals Queen okay and then I'll
take that well that was one only legal
who so I played it now he's fresh out of
ideas I'm waiting I you pawn takes
Bishop let's let's take that Queen now
what Queen f6 but by night is still here
my Knights retreating like a Frenchman
okay so that doesn't work you pawn takes
Bishop
we're here then I could block with the
rook I could block with the Queen or I
could retreat also like what I'm telling
you stuff you should try to listen like
when I said he had the right answer what
was his answer nobody listens either out
to their fellow competitors Queen f6 the
right answer then when I took his Queens
like I give up so if it's meetin - now
it's meetin one yes
incorrect but let's not even check so
it's not me you with the right answer
don't make me look bad is making me look
bad all the way in the back pawn takes
Bishop checkmate I don't think that's
checkmate there's a lot of black pieces
that could take that yeah terrible yeah
Maidan 1 it's too hard for this class
charge and the bathrooms down there yes
Ricki 7 my king could take or my Queen
could take maybe one is too hard
yes G one here that's checkmate so if
it's checkmate in one move I need a
checkmate you d8 and then a knight
checkmate see you're the best player in
your chair
he's like Queen B - Queen f6 then he's
like all I give up but you're right
never give up
right Ben Simon Ben Simon just just give
up yeah it's true
Ben Simon the king of the two-game batch
very suspicious okay then that was my
game against Magnus Carlsen he thought
he was going to checkmate me here and I
Pro to a night with mate and then he
started crying okay class dismissed
now go play chess